ja wir haben jetzt Weihnachten vor uns
und alle laufen in die Regale rein und
was macht der Handel erstellt uns
Produkte rein von denen wir nicht mehr
wissen wie lange die eigentlich halten
werden da muss man ja schon bald Angst
haben dass die meisten
Weihnachtsgeschenke nächstes Jahr schon
wieder kaputt sind und wie kommt es die
meisten Produkte werden eben heute so
gebaut dass sie maximal die
Gewährleistungszeit überstehen also zwei
Jahre viele gehen schon vorher kaputt
für einen vielen gibt es schon vorher
gar keine Ersatzteile mehr muss im Regal
und da wünsche ich mir eigentlich dann
doch eher dass der Handel endlich mal
dafür sorgt dass wir wieder sorglos
einkaufen gehen können heute muss man ja
sozusagen eine detekte ein Gründen bevor
man den Weihnachtsgeschäft rein möchte
nicht um eben zu finden ja bitte welche
Produkte sind das die ich hier noch
kaufen kann wo nachher meine Kinder zu
mir kommen und sagen was hast du mir
dafür murksgeschenke schon wieder kaputt
gegangen ich habe mal meine Tochter die
wollte unbedingt haben Schuhe aus dem
Billigladen in Berlin überhaupt ja nach
drei na ich glaube drei Wochen kann sie
schon wieder eine Sache ja hat nicht
gehalten die geht dann nie wieder
einkaufen nicht also wir sollten einfach
beim Einkaufen darauf achten Haltbarkeit
wie macht man das ich habe heute gelesen
40% der Menschen sind mittlerweile
einverstanden sich etwas Gebrauchtes zu
Weihnachten schenken zu lassen das finde
ich eigentlich eine ganz tolle Sache es
gibt heute neuwertige Dinge die man sich
online kaufen kann auf aufgebraucht
Börsen ebay etc was ist da alles gibt
das heißt wir haben für uns selbst die
Möglichkeit vielleicht einfach mal neu
nachzudenken das schönste wäre finde ich
angesichts der Einsamkeit die sich an
vielen Orten breit macht die
gesprächsbedürfnisse die da sind die
Krisen den Druck der auf uns lastet der
da ist das wichtigste ist wir schenken
einander mal wieder Zeit reden über die
Dinge unter Handel sollte endlich dafür
sorgen dass er seine Regale aufräumt
denn geplante Obsoleszenz hat dort
nichts zu suchen das klingt wenn ich das
höre fast für mich wie nach Betrug ich
gehe jetzt völlig naiv im Laden und
denke das was ich kaufe das wird ja wohl
halten früher hatten Auto 1 Millionen
Kilometer geschafft gibt's heute einfach
nicht mehr würden sie selbst von Betrug
sprechen
kann ungefähr 80% der Konsumgüter ohne
Mehrkosten mit dreifacher Haltbarkeit
herstellen das heißt doch vom Marketing
her tolle Sache ich sag dem einen mach
mal haltbarer da können wir ja noch mal
ein bisschen was drauf schlagen bitte
nicht gierig sein das heißt ich könnte
in der Summe nachher mehr Grenze Ertrag
nennen wir das machen obwohl wir kaum
Grenzkosten haben nicht wenig
reinstecken ein bisschen aufschlagen die
Dinge halten länger wir haben Ressourcen
Probleme heute in den Unternehmen das
sehen wir ja durch Corona schon immer
weniger Produkte waren Stoffe kommt zu
uns nach Europa wenn die Dinge länger
halten haben weil weniger Sorgen weil es
einfach länger da ist das ist
wirtschaftlich sinnvoll das ist für ein
Konsumenten das ist für die Umweltschutz
das ist für alles mögliche sind voll
nicht und dann muss man wirklich sagen
geplante ob soll es Seins also das
mutwillige Kurzlebigkeit einbauen
einfach blöd anscheinenden sie so
zufrieden mit der Politik jetzt aber
muss man sagen da kommt schon ganz
schöne Kritik auch hoch neben Ihnen
sitzt jemand aus der Politik sie
begleiten dieses Thema glaube ich 20
Jahren das ist
ich mache heute alle Eltern hier in
dieser Sendung
danke als vereinbar wirksam als wäre es
20 Jahre tätig gewesen aber viel
wichtiger ist ja in Frankreich gibt es
schon Gesetze in Deutschland ist geplant
Obsoleszenz leider immer noch erlaubt
den passt ganz Europa ist geplante
Obsoleszenz immer noch erlaubt in
Italien ist Apple schon verurteilt
worden wegen gefahren
wir haben vor der Sendung gesprochen und
ich kann das nicht sagen weil ich in dem
Bereich nicht tätig bin ich bin ja im
Wirtschaft und nicht im Umweltbereich wo
das dann angesiedelt ist ich weiß aber
dass es sowas wie ein Recht auf
Reparatur schon in Schweden gibt dass
die Europäische Union auch entsprechende
Pläne genau was hat also es gibt nicht
funktionieren und ich kann jetzt nicht
vorstellen dass wir das nicht wollen
aber ich kann nicht sagen wo der Stadt
könnten sie sich ja mal connecten nennen
sicherlich haben Sie ja auch Interesse
daran das Gerät lange halten dass man
die ganze Zeit sie haben schon Kärtchen
ausgesprochen
und mein zwei Jahre altes Handy ist
nicht mehr angesprungen und dann bin ich
zu einer Reparatur Laden Gefahren wieder
aufgemacht ist gut dass sie repariert
aber das Handy nach zwei Jahren dann
einfach nicht mehr funktioniert ist halt
auch wieder so ein Problem treffen sich
Menschen machen gemeinsam Dinge in
repair Cafés 42 repair Cafés 1600
ungefähr in Deutschland schon eine ganz
Europa hat sich das ausgebreitet ja ich
habe vor kurzem gesehen wie ein Junge
sein Vater auf dem Kopf gehauen hat weil
er gehört hat mensch du hättest mir
löten beibringen können dann kann ich
mal wieder was also Kolben zu
Weihnachten schenken top Geschenke ja
Zauberstab der heutigen Zeit habe
ihn total recht secondhand da bin ich
mit dabei und bei Produkten draufschauen
sind sie verklebt stehen lassen ja
verklebte Produkte den Verkäuferin wie
mache ich das eigentlich auch da gibt es
Stabmixer die sind komplett verklebt
wenn der kaputt geht ist ein
Einwegprodukte da geben Sie also 40 €
von Stabmixer aussehen könnte Abschluss
nach zwei Jahren wegschmeißen weil der
ist nicht mehr reparierbar ist doch
gruselig das ist wirklich ja und
anschauen einfach mal hin gucken nach
dem Motto die Gelenke die kommt also
alles was ich irgendwie nur bewegen
könnte dann Nutzungszeit anschauen wenn
das klappt nicht aussieht stehen lassen
aber viel wichtiger mal den Chef her
rufen und sagen Sie mal rum stellen sie
morgen ins Regal ich gehe bei ihm bald
nicht mehr einkaufen